dans paris direct info ou intox
info ou intox avec anthony sur les
géants tony dron soit on sort clairement
soir atos est alors qu emmanuel macron
était hier lundi à moscou et ce mardi à
kiev pour aboutir à une désescalade en
ukraine depuis plusieurs semaines les
spéculations sur l'imminence d'une
invasion russe vont bon train oui la
preuve encore ce soir avec deux vidéos
tik tok décortiqué par côte de ger
verture base des observateurs de france
24 on va en garder une la première des
militaires qui courent tir qui
s'abritent dans des maisons en ruines on
entend aussi des coups de feu est la
vidéo que vous voyez elle était partagée
en espagne heures essentiellement depuis
le 23 janvier une poupée prime une part
de 2 37 minutes un retour sur la
publication regarder cette publication
qui portent le logo rt pour rush atouts
d'air n'enchaîne l'on sait la chaîne
d'info en continu financé par le kremlin
et 7l légende en espagnol l'armée russe
détruits et envahi une petite ville
d'ukraine qu'en est il réellement une
simple recherche sur youtube nous donne
la réponse avec trois hameaux claire
thépaut russia today donc et puis
military roussos militaire russe en
espagnol l'une des occurrences c'est
cette vidéo que l'on trouve ici avec le
stylo c'est mieux on la trouve ici et là
voici cette vidéo on retrouve bien les
mêmes images une vidéo qui naquit a été
publié en fait le 5 mars 2019 sur la
chaîne youtube en espagnol de russia
today on n'est pas en ukraine mais en
syrie il s'agit d'instructeurs
militaires russes qui entraîne des
membres des forces de l'armée arabe
syrienne à alep et on peut d'ailleurs
repéré a notamment ici sur l'uniforme
l'écusson en correspondance justement
ces forces de l'armée arabe syrienne est
toujours sur tik tok une seconde vidéo
fait état d'un nouvel arsenal nucléaire
russe récent et à tort envoyé plus de
700 mhz et 700 milles vu depuis une
semaine pour cette vidéo regardez on y
voit vladimira poutine fasse un public
et plusieurs engins et militaires qui
sont montrés dans un écran et la légende
de dire le nouveau jouet nucléaire de
poutine légende pourtant trompeuse parce
que comme souvent c'est la recherche à
l'image inversée qui nous met la puce à
l'oreille vous faites ici la capture
d'écran de la vidéo vous l'a glissée
dans un moteur de recherche en
l'occurrence et yandex le mode est le
moteur de recherche russe et vous
retombez sur l'un des résultats celui-ci
l'une d'une émission italienne
d'actualité tg 2000 ce qui explique donc
ce logo ici dans la vidéo virale c'est
la chaîne youtube italienne
correspondante et cette émission elle
date du 2 mars 2018 et lorsqu'on
effectue une recherche complémentaire
avec cette date on tombe sur des
articles notamment ceux de france 24
évoquant ce discours de vladimir poutine
devant des députés et des sénateurs on
est le 1er mars 2018 alors ils
présentaient bien en effet son arsenal
nucléaire pour je cite mettre en garde
ses agresseurs potentiels mais cette
vidéo comme l'hôte précédemment n'ont
absolument rien à voir avec la situation
en ukraine actuellement et les intox
concernant la poutine ont la vie dure
oui hier on sait la rencontre entre
vladimir poutine emmanuel macron a donné
lieu à deux nombreux à détournements
dont je n'ai pas pu m'empêcher de vous
faire part à simon ristic vous le
reconnaître la taille de la table qui
les séparaient a donné lieu finalement à
la fare alais voilà elle a fait beaucoup
parler d'elle et celle ci a été à
rallonge et toutes les options sont sur
la table il y en a beaucoup voilà pour
la petite blague pas de quoi crier alain
fox puisqu'on le voit ces trucages sont
évidents mais ce n'est pas toujours le
cas et à la faveur justement de ce qui
se joue actuellement à la frontière
ukrainienne une vidéo est revenu sur le
devant de la scène ces derniers jours et
notamment depuis fin janvier après que
emmanuel macron a déclaré que la riposte
sera là et que le coup sera très élevé
en cas d'agression russe et cette vidéo
la voix si elle est on va la remettre au
début elle est censée montrer emmanuel
macron snobé par vladimir poutine
regardez vladimir poutine qui
snoberaient donc emmanuel macron pour
une poignée de main du petit lait pour
ses détracteurs l'idée accro faible face
à un maître du kremlin fort comment
s'imposer quand on a subi une telle
humiliation sauf que comme ont décrypté
les observateurs de france 24 il ya
quelques mois déjà avec plusieurs
d'autres à plusieurs autres exemples et
bien à cette séquence elle a été
volontairement tronquée voici l'original
on est à la cérémonie à paris du
centenaire de l'armistice de 1918 et la
poigne et bien il y a bien eu à la fois
entre brigitte macro emmanuel macron
allez on va finir en musique ah oui avec
cette vidéo claire regarder et surtout
écouter les premières notes
vous reconnaissez certainement ses notes
de seven nation army des white stripes
sont nés en 2003 interprété ici au piano
par vladimir poutine dans cette vidéo
qui a ressurgi ces derniers jours la
définition même du frisson nous dit par
exemple cet internaute au regard du
contexte a qui se joue justement en
ukraine on se rappelle les paroles je
vais combattre est tous une armée de
cette nation ne pourrais pas me retenir
voilà donc pour les premières paroles
toute ressemblance avec la situation ou
l'allusion une quelconque alliance
atlantique est évidemment fortuite ces
images qui porte le logo de l' agence de
presse russe foot knicks se sont en fait
vu ajouter de la musique car l'original
la voilà en étant 2017 à regarder
écouter à nouveau
[Musique]
alors vous voyez ça n'a absolument rien
à voir cette vidéo détournée de spoutnik
avait déjà circulé à l'époque il ya
quatre ans c'est le vladimir poutine qui
s'adonne donc au piano juste avant une
rencontre avec son homologue xi jingping
on est appelé cao interlude improvisé
presque sans fausse note merci beaucoup
anthony st léger c'était info ou intox
qu'on peut retrouver sur notre site
internet
www.francebillet.com rester avec nous
paris direct continue on se retrouve
dans quelques instants après une courte
pause
[Musique]